all right let's read this story from cnn
biden's comments about pandemic widen
public health split over how u.s should
respond to kovid 19 i love this they say
even as the u.s prepares for a potential
winter surge of kobe 19 president biden
roamed the cavernous halls of the
detroit auto show for an interview on
cbs's 60 minutes and gesturing to the
mostly masculine attendees told the
nation the pandemic is over we still
have a problem with covid we're still
doing a lot of work on it he told scott
pelley but the pandemic is over he
repeated let's give a round of applause
to everybody yeah it's all over
everybody everybody can go home or or
leave your home because the pandemic's
over it's so crazy to me that here to
hear this and then you know i go out and
i still see people wearing masks in
places that don't require them
yeah they must not know that the
pandemic's over yet maybe maybe they
needed this maybe maybe now joe biden's
sweet whispers will uh it'll wage their
fears it will a lot of people wait
unfortunately for better for worse they
wait for the official word and this is
the most official word you're going to
get